i guess some of the intuition of the
proof of this uh this sort of automated
inequality
approver um i guess yeah so i should say
by um
uh can i write on this or no
no
um
okay um sorry and i have 20 minutes
roughly
um um
okay yes i i i should have said this
yesterday but um
so yesterday i was talking about kind of
this idea of trying to get some instance
optimal algorithms
um so this is like not a new thing so in
kind of the cs theory game theory
there's been a long line of work trying
to do this some really nice work on
um so geometric algorithms trying to get
sort of instance optimal in terms of
runtime
a lot of game theory work on instance
optimal in terms of you know
revenue maximization um and then related
to this distributional stuff there's
a lot of work a lot of it actually from
um from alan rolitsky and
and his group and the students and on um
so yeah so this isn't a new idea but i'm
trying to
push people to to think about this uh um
these problems really in terms of how do
you get sort of
provable guarantees and algorithms that
really work nicely in practice
um so okay anyway so today i was i was
going to try to give some high level
intuition of this um
characterization of inequalities so um
so yes the theorem is the following
um
so given some sequences
ai bi and ci
um and say each of these is our terms
um
the theorem is it holds that
for all positive sequences
xj and yj
um
following is true product over i
this time over j of x j to the a
i y j to the b i
this i this is always greater than one
if and only if this can be expressed as
a finite product of holder type
inequalities and lp management sd
inequalities which i'll say
so by finite i mean polynomial in r
i guess it'll probably be something like
r cubed in practice r
is usually like at worst five or six but
um so finite
so this is kind of the first claim and
the second claim
is that in some sense this
characterization is algorithmic so there
exists
an efficient algorithm polynomial in the
representation lengths of a b and c that
will
um tell you is this always true if it is
it'll tell you how to prove it it'll
tell you this decomposition
if it's not true it'll give you some
witness um
algorithmic slash constructive
um
okay so just uh i guess i'll write it
here so
okay so you know so what's holders
inequality what are these lp
modification
inequalities so i'm just going to write
them here because
um we're going to refer to them so
um okay so the usual holder inequality
says if you have some um
if you have some lambda in zero one
then sum over a
j lambda
sum over e j to the one minus lambda
that's greater than or equal to the sum
of a
j lambda b j
so these a's and b's are positive okay
and of course we can put any
you know combination of powers of x and
y in for the a's and b's okay
so so what does this mean this just
means that for any um
say a1 a2 b1 b2
just plugging in plugging in xj to a1
times yj to the b1 in here
and the corresponding thing here with
the twos
we just get
equal to you know the corresponding
thing um
okay yes okay so this is our holder
inequality
and the analogous sort of lp
monotonicity inequality
um so this is just the fact that
like the lp norm of something is
monotonically decreasing i guess as a
function of p
sorry this is just the sum of aj
lambda less than equal to sum of aj
to lambda i guess for any lambda and
zero one
and again we can plug in any kind of
xjyj thing in for the a's here
um
um
okay so
um so how would we might how would you
know
we try to go about proving this so i
just wanted to give one example which
gives some intuition that
we probably shouldn't you could try to
express some program that says find me
sequences
that like invalidate this okay
and i just want to give one example to
illustrate so this is actually not a
good way of going about this
okay so one example um
so for some epsilon that's greater than
or equal to zero
consider the following thing so sum of
x minus two
minus one x minus one
zero to the two minus so minus two minus
epsilon
okay so so this corresponds to this
thing where all the y's the coefficients
of y are all zero
and it's not too hard to convince
yourself so this is actually this holds
true if epsilon equals zero
and it's false for every positive
epsilon
so in other words there exists a
sequence x that falsifies it
for any epsilon greater than zero
there exists a sequence of x's that
falsify this
but the shortest um
counter example the shortest falsifying
sequence
there's a sequence of length
exponential and i guess order one over
epsilon
okay so in other words if you want to
try to
so the more what's the moral of this
example um
the moral is if you want to try to prove
this you shouldn't be trying to
construct some
something that will actually populate
these sets x's and y's
because there might be extremely long
sequences
um okay so
so how should one think about this so
i'm going to give a nice geometric
interpretation of how to think about
this
and the proof will more or less fall out
via some lp programming
are people okay with this i don't really
want to give the intuition for what's
going on but
is it supposed to be easy to see that
for all epsilon positive
you can find a sequence that will
violate it um
if not that's fine but
uh no okay it shouldn't it shouldn't be
easy to see but this
so this x to the so this is just the
number of elements of the sequence
and basically you're kind of going to
play off this epsilon with
uh yeah sorry it shouldn't be obvious
yeah i just wanted to kind of give you
the flavor of what these sequences look
like
so in particular you know we don't even
have two different there's no there's no
y it's just one thing
and even just for these um you know we
have a term that's basically the number
of terms
this there's some epsilon there and
that's kind of yeah just kind of
yeah just just notice kind of the flavor
of this it's something very reasonable
but one of the exponents is just shy of
what you want it to be
it's a great to so i'm understanding
on the left there's sort of a finite
number of ai's that you're given
and on the right we're allowed to take
differences if arbitrary length
yes so so yeah we want i give you like
so
you know holder's inequality corresponds
to
right there there are three terms this
term this term and this term
so these a's b's and c's are sequences
of length three
oh no i'm sorry okay and we want to know
you give me this you want to know is it
true that for all positive x's and y's
all the other sequences sorry i was just
confused
yes this is i mean proving inequalities
like this
i know it comes up more than i would
wish in my life and
yeah um all right
okay so to try to get some geometry out
of this
um think of the following so
um
okay so i claim that any positive
sequences
x j y j
they def they define a function
they define some function l which maps
the plane
to the real numbers where
l of a comma b is equal to the logarithm
of the sum over j of x j to the a
y j to the b
i'm just i'm defining this function l
what properties does l satisfy
well you know what is this
well this is like the logarithm of one
of our terms so
if we had taken the law what does
soldiers inequality say about
l any any guesses
so if we take the log of holders
inequality what do we get
we get that lambda
times l of a1 b1
plus you know the logarithm of this term
plus 1 minus lambda
l of a2 b2 is greater than or equal to
l of you know this thing
the convex combination of a1 and a2
so lambda a1 plus one minus lambda
a2 comma you know the thing with the b's
what is this it says that l is convex
right okay good so what do we know so l
is convex
what does this lp monetization tell us
about this function
well again just taking the logs it says
that lambda times l of a comma b
is less than or equal to l of lambda a
comma lambda v
so this is from holder and
we also know that lambda
l of a comma b
is less than or equal to l of lambda a
lambda b so what does this mean
so this is a function from you know the
plane to r
some surface holders inequality tells us
it must be convex
this says if you take any point on this
like
on the surface and draw a line towards
the origin
you draw the secant line from the
surface towards the origin
in the xy plane and the a b plane it
tells you it must pass
on or above sorry it must pass through
or above
the origin in the y direction so we have
this convex surface
any secant that goes towards the origin
you know must pass through the origin or
above the origin
right that's what this tells you as you
as you go towards the origin
the actual value of l is greater than
what happens if you just interpolate
this point towards the origin
okay so these are two things we know
about l
is there some condition under which the
second to follow from convexity
say this one the second inequality is it
doesn't follow from complexity under
some other
awesome question so the question is
basically are these two really different
inequalities or not and i think they are
i mean if you look at the
you know the the case where holders is
tight
is different when this is tight the case
where this is tight is just where it's a
single element
the case where holders inequality is
tight or where these two things have the
um
whatever are have the same proportion
right
yeah great great question
so initially we didn't know about this
and we just thought maybe holders was
all there is
the proof almost goes through but then
basically you're trying to say something
about this
convex thing but there's no there's
nothing keeping it up from below
like there's none of this weird secant
property going through the origin blah
blah blah
and somehow the proof falls out from
beneath you
in a very literal sense um so yeah so i
think this is actually i mean
it is different okay so um
so armed with this geometry the proof is
basically going to say
you give me any function l that
satisfies these two properties
and i will be able to populate it i will
be able to find sequences x
and y that
realize your function l very closely
at whatever finite set of points you
wish okay so let's make
so i'll just write um
what i actually mean by that
okay so the proof of the theorem is sort
of
basically the following we're going to
construct a linear program
that has r variables
the variables i'll say li
and you should think of li as being a
proxy for
li should be roughly l of a i comma bi
which is going to be roughly the log of
think of it as the log of the sum of
x to the a i y to the bi okay
and the linear program is basically
going to say
can can we um find some function l
satisfying these properties that
violates this
so namely it's going to say minimize
the sum of ci times li
ci times li is literally the logarithm
of this expression
when you interpret li as this form may
not like this such that
what are the constraints going to say
well the constraints are going to say
look li
should actually be sort of consistent
with something like this such that
let's say the convex or the lower convex
hull
the lower hull
of the set of points a i b i li
is convex
and then our second constraint namely
any secant to this lower hull
that goes towards the origin must pass
through or above the origin
okay so
what's going on so the first claim is
i claim that these constraints i mean
you can write these as some
linear sorry some finite um
set of holder type inequalities and lp
monitor nested inequalities
so i claim that you can actually write
the constraints of the linear program as
folder and lp type module
sorry and lv mountainous inequalities
given that
this ends up being a homogeneous linear
program there are no
the right side of all the constraints
are zero okay so if the minimum of this
is zero this means that by lp duality
there's a finite positive combination of
the constraints
which verify which which end up implying
that this is like greater than or equal
to zero okay so if
the minimum is zero then
linear programming duality gives you a
proof of this
via combinations of these constraints
which is exactly our algorithmic
characterization okay
if this is less than zero if the often
less than zero
then we basically need to show that
these constraints on li
are sufficient in order to construct
these sequences
x and y which isn't so hard
okay so this is basically saying you're
telling me what you want
the log of this sum to be at a bunch of
points and i just need to find
x's and y's that are very close at these
points
anyway so i thought is this okay some
people look happy some people don't look
happy
we can ask questions while the next
speaker
is right so
this this holding her knot is seems
super fragile to the
ai's bic right as you showed me a
counter example if you shift one by
epsilon
does
yesterday how do you take care of these
numerical precision issues
ah okay so actually so
um because we're dealing with the ls not
with the sequences
x and y it actually ends up being
extremely numerically precise
um so so like we have this matlab code
it'll literally write out in english
your thing equals the product of these
holder inequalities and these lp
monotonicity inequalities
so so right so it's because because
we're working with these l's
we're sort of allowed to scale things so
basically i mean
yeah if this is if if you can falsify
this you can falsify it by
as much as you want okay and because of
that you sort of uh
things end up being robust in this view
and i guess yeah just one last comment
was um
the geometric game i showed in
yesterday's talk where you're sliding
points around
this is literally playing with the dual
constraints
trying to do your thing and trying to
prove the duel so it's
that game is literally like what can you
do with the duel of this linear